welcome to this video is so called with
black yeah international masters so
choline yeah
played him number of times recently
let's see okay with g3
yeah g3 is not a very it's not a very
exciting way to play this position
definitely an okay way but not a very
exciting one Queen Sade is a specialty
nothing nothing brilliant admittedly but
it's a move that keeps a little bit more
tension in the position then then usual
with some some other continuations okay
a five quincy it covers the bishop and
prepare c5 this was the idea
Knight b3 is a slightly curious curious
answer to be honest I don't really
understand the move what is happening
here yeah he just is just about keeping
his material cheek you can cheek b3 and
I'm sure before is it's a bit annoying
of course I don't have anything in there
right okay so let's do that and then
this is this it was clear that this is a
playable means but I was looking for
something better but didn't didn't find
anything okay
maybe 986 yeah this is some has gotten
this is now getting them kind of a
Queen's Indian flavor this pollution the
bishop on b7 how did I do that I can go
here yeah maybe this just taking a the
ape horn and while the move a3 is
something that y definitely doesn't want
to play making making his beep on
backward or backwards uh-huh so
something is trying something sharp well
I can just take a - right I mean I can
take evil as well and why what is the
the big issue with this I mean if I
cannot take it I don't see why okay if I
can if he gives me this central pawn
I'll take it
I really fail to see the idea that was
the idea okay now that that I didn't
didn't really consider I thought that
well this is always should be good with
the discovery on the Queen okay and e6
now simply add any takes okay I
understand
oh oh oh Nathan this wasn't really great
what I did yeah
that was stupid hmm these six rook c5
how annoying I take the other move the
knight yeah I guess I have to do that
but this is definitely not what I wanted
I mean maybe it is still okay but this
wasn't my original intention when I when
I am allowed all that ya
counter-attacking of the night so if he
takes if I if I'm going to take here
will be eight queen chicks and it's not
possible really maybe just here
preventing preventing before and
attacking the pawn
so currently I'm a pawn app so is there
a way to keep it I can't can maybe just
do here right oopsie eight covering that
my back rank is really weak
what g6 is this d6 any better I don't
know probably not need to make sure that
I'm not back renovated so h6 probably
makes some sense
Queen b6 yeah
whoo he's allowing a c5 and this is this
I need to do really getting rid of my
backwards upon
yeah not sure don't have much time so
try to try to be quicker with my pawns
looks it took 21 but it gets very
critical now fan his pieces he are not
very well coordinated the rukon III and
Queen and stuff
okay five rook c5 as a possibility group
the eight is also good a time trying to
take it okay 40 seconds hmm okay check
ah no ah come on ah losing this game
no really yeah yeah after a one-week
break
you're really rusty right really I mean
losing it was really pretty much
impossible
okay so Jeroboam I mean of course
any-anything wins yeah except what I did
okay for or whatever - 12 maybe this is
of course also winning I just I just
simply as assembly didn't didn't didn't
didn't think about Queen f7 yeah I mean
any move Queen c6 or whatever yeah it
was so yeah it was a very strange
somehow
I can also play d6 yeah and then this is
really really awful yeah allowing c5 as
long as my sheep one is on c7 he always
has some pressure against apology just
played this and after see if I hear
black really wins it's just not nothing
more nothing less
now I need to elite some games to get
into stride again I'm recording this
video here and a batch of videos
after my vacation so I'm pretty rusty I
didn't do any chess on my vacation and
all okay well thanks for watching